I watched her TED talk and you said the  more technologically advanced our  society becomes the more we need to go  back to the basic fundamentals of human  communication how do we get back to the  basics of human communication when there  seems to be a new device around every  corner but I think that's where the  human connection comes in you know I  don't care how advanced technology gets  I don't think that there's anything that  could replace looking someone the eyes  touching their hand you know that  feeling if you will that I don't care  how many millions of Facebook friends  you have you don't get that feeling so I  do think that it's getting back to this  incredible human connection and and  isn't that how incredible things happen  as well